[Musique]
le conseil d'état se prononcera demain
sur l'utilité publique du projet de
ligne à grande vitesse paris lyon le tgv
sans attendre son avis dont il y a tout
lieu de penser qu'il sera positif
la sncf vient de passer la première
commande du matériel roulant destiné à
l'équipement de la nouvelle ligne
chaque rame comportera deux motrices
encadrant deux voitures de première et
deuxième classe offrant au total 382
places assises vitesse de pointe 300
kilomètres à l'heure mais la lure de
croisière sera limité dans un premier
temps à 260 km à l'heure une performance
qui mettra dans six ans lyon à deux
heures et dijon à 1h37 de paris
l'utilité du projet est vivement
contesté par des associations pour la
protection de la nature
leurs critiques sont réfutés par la sncf
qui affirme que l'emprise d'une voie
ferrée est très étroite et consomme donc
peu d'hectares le tgv traversera la
bourgogne sur 265 km et immobilisera
1600 hectares dans l'yonne en côte d'or
et en saône et loire
[Musique]